Esta es Hong Kong.
Si eres adinerado, vives aquí; si eres pobre, vives aquí;
la alta densidad está por todo ello.
Y no es solo Asia.
En São Paulo, puedes viajar en helicóptero 45 minutos
viendo como los altos edificios consumen el ambiente de baja altura del siglo 19.
Y con esto viene el congestionamiento, y perdemos movilidad y así sucesivamente.
Y entonces, hace algunos años decidimos volver y repensar Habitat.
¿Podríamos volverlo más asequible?
¿Podríamos, en verdad, lograr esta calidad de vida
en las densidades que hoy en día predominan?
Y nos dimos cuenta de que se trata básicamente de luz,
se trata del sol, se trata de naturaleza,
se trata de fractalización.
¿Podemos abrir la superficie del edificio para tener más contacto con el exterior?
Se nos ocurrieron una serie de modelos; modelos económicos,
más baratos de construir y más compactos; membranas de alojamiento
donde uno pudiera diseñar su propia casa y crear sus propios jardines.
Y decidimos probar con Nueva York, y nos enfocamos en el Bajo Manhattan.
Y trazamos el mapa del área edificada de Manhattan.
A la izquierda está Manhattan hoy en día: azul para las casas,
rojo para edificios de oficinas, almacenes.
A la derecha, lo reconfiguramos: los edificios de oficinas forman la base,
y subiendo 74 pisos, están los apartamentos.
Hay una calle en el aire en el 25º piso, una calle colectiva.
Es piramidal.
Hay jardines y espacios abiertos para la comunidad,
casi todas las unidades con su propio jardín privado,
y espacios colectivos por todo ello.
Y lo más importante: permeable, abierto.
No constituye una pared o una obstrucción en la cuidad,
y la luz penetra en todas partes.
Y en los últimos dos o tres años, hemos estado, por primera vez,
materializando la calidad de vida en el Habitat
en proyectos de la vida real por toda Asia.
Esta es Qinhuangdao en China, casas de clase media
donde se pone como condición que todo apartamento debe recibir
tres horas de luz solar, y medidas en el solsticio de inverno.
Y, en construcción, en Singapur, de nuevo, casas de clase media, jardines,
calles colectivas, parques y así sucesivamente.
Y en Colombo.
Pero quiero referirme a algo más, al diseño del espacio público.
Cien años después de haber empezado a construir
con edificios altos, todavía tenemos que comprender
cómo los edificios de gran altura se vuelven un bloque de construcción
al crear una ciudad,
al crear el espacio público.
En Singapur, tuvimos una oportunidad: 930 mil metros cuadrados,
densidad extremamente alta, desarrollo de los conceptos
de exterior e interior, paseos y parques integrados
con una vida urbana intensa.
Y entonces hay espacios exteriores y espacios interiores,
y uno se mueve de uno a otro.
Y hay contacto con la naturaleza, y lo más relevante,
en cada nivel de la estructura, jardines públicos y espacios abiertos.
En lo más alto del podio, arriba de las torres,
sobre el techo, finalmente el parque del cielo:
una hectárea, pistas de atletismo, restaurantes,
y la piscina más larga del mundo.
Y esto es todo lo que puedo contarles en cinco minutos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)